[Music]  you're going on a journey  a journey through memory all you have to  do is follow my voice  we're closed i know i'm sorry it's late  we have time for one more job  when the waters began to rise and war  broke out  nostalgia became a way of life  there wasn't a lot to look forward to  so people began looking back  nothing is more addictive than the  put me back past me back  she has moved on and you should too  people don't just  vanish to find where she'd gone i had to  know where she'd been  where is he where is she  [Music]  arson bribery murder people love their  secrets  don't go down this path stay here in  this life  i've turned the blind eye to plenty i  have to do this  [Music]  that machine of yours how close can you  get  before the illusion's broken  you're going on a journey all you have  to do is follow my voice  [Music]  [Music]  you